-Hi, there!
-Hi!
-Oh, my God,
I'm so happy you're back.
And we've talked since,
but let me just say in person,
congratulations
on an incredible job
at the Correspondents' Dinner.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And how did, uh...
-It was -- It was --
It went great,
and every single person
loved it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Every single person
across the board.
-Across the board. Yeah, yeah.
-Never happened before.
-No, everyone loved it.
Even, actually,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
called me,
and she was like,
"I loved it so much.
I got every joke."
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-'Cause I was watching.
There were a few
that seemed like she maybe
didn't like or get.
-Well, you know, you give
the best information
you have at the time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a philosophy.
-You will be very happy.
There was a tweet that I saw,
and knowing our relationship,
I thought you were just
going love this.
This is basically -- C-SPAN
posted that in three days,
you became the most-watched
Correspondents' Dinner ever.
You beat me.
So, basically, in what
it took me seven years to do,
you outdid me in three years.
-Yeah, I'm gonna frame that.
-Yeah, you outdid me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well deserved.
-It's great.
Yeah, I think that --
I think that means I'm the
father of your children now.
-Yeah, I think that might be --
that might be it.
-They're mine now.
-So, I want to ask you
about another photo.
This is afterwards.
This is a bunch of your writers.
-[ Laughs ]
-You were just finished,
and you walked into a party,
and this photo, I think,
was maybe even in
"The New York Times."
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-What is everybody chanting
as you walked in?
-They're chanting,
"Lock her up!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A perfect -- A perfect way
to end the evening.
Obviously, you had --
This blows my mind,
'cause you were preparing for
the Correspondents' Dinner,
you're preparing for your new
show that I want to talk about,
but you also had time to train,
and then run, a 50-mile race.
-Yeah.
-And I know you to be a runner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What convinced you
to try to do 50 miles at once?
-Well, I wanted to do --
It's an ultra marathon.
And I wanted to do that because,
like, anyone can do a marathon.
Like, even you did a marathon.
-Yeah, I've done one.
-Except for that one...
-Yeah.
-...that you didn't finish.
-Well, I had a leg injury.
-But you didn't finish.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You couldn't do it, yeah.
-I could have hobbled and done,
like, more damage to my leg.
-Or you could have sucked it up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, I didn't.
So, but if you --
-Most people power through it.
[ Light laughter ]
-Where did you do your 50-mile?
-It was in the Salt Flats
in Utah.
And, oh. [ Laughs ]
[ Light laughter ]
We have a salt flat here.
-Or just someone who --
They just might be
someone who loves salt.
-Yeah, it's great. It's just...
No, so then I spent the weekend
in Utah,
and that's Mormon country.
And I was at -- I was with
my nephews at a playground.
I wasn't by myself, I promise.
[ Light laughter ]
But there is this guy
at the playground
wearing a T-shirt
that said, "Porn kills love."
At the playground!
-Yeah.
-With the children!
-Right.
-'Cause they need to know.
-[ Laughs ] That's true.
-But I was like -- I was like,
regardless of your feelings
about porn,
like, graphic tees
definitely kill love.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- No one has ever been
like, "Oh, a graphic tee!
I feel like that manatee now."
[ Laughter ]
-That's how I proposed.
I wore a "Will you marry me?"
[ Laughter ]
So you're preparing
for your Netflix show.
-Yeah.
-This is very exciting.
How has preparation gone so far?
-It's great.
I would have to say
that if you hated
the Correspondents' Dinner,
you're really going to
hate this show.
[ Laughter ]
-That, I think, is good to hear
for a lot of people.